uh some quarterback injury updates
unrelated to monday night cramps drew
brees activated to return to practice a
three-week window is now open for him to
return to the active roster you get a
little bit of a free roster spot here
during this three weeks he can practice
he doesn't count toward the 53-man
roster at some point he needs to be put
on the 53-man roster whether or not he's
ready to play his status for sunday is
uncertain said coach sean payton on
wednesday in speaking to reporters we
haven't ruled anything out just because
we don't have to he's got a ways to go
still and he's someone we're not going
to hurry back and just put him in the
game i think it was jay glazer who
reported over the weekend that it's
highly unlikely that brees will play on
sunday for the saints against the chiefs
the more likely return for brees would
be christmas day against the minnesota
vikings
and i've seen the
100 percent rule or something close to
it i think it was shefty on monday night
that they aren't going to play him until
he's nearly 100
anytime i hear that i think we're
holding open the possibility of riding
with the backup
as long as the backups playing at an
acceptably high level and you know
there's
that's the ultimate balance that a team
has to deal with do we want
starting quarterback at whatever
percentage he may be less than 100 or do
we want backup at 100. it depends on who
the backup is and it depends on who the
starter is
yeah and it depends on you know where
you are as a football team during the
season right i mean i think that's
another you know part of the
conversation too and where do you hold
yourself in regards to the rest of the
nfl as far as your chances to make a run
in the playoffs of the super bowl in a
year
where
yeah of course the saints would like to
play in the dome and there's the whole
drew brees and bad weather conversation
all that but you know as we know home
field advantage is less important this
year than ever before so
okay let's not sacrifice the season just
to rush back drew brees five days
earlier than he should or whatever you
know so i think it's the smart move
they're clearly one of the best teams in
the nfc they're gonna have one of the
higher seeds we know that
and that rib injury for his age you know
we talked about it a lot one we know
it's probably still delicate when he
throws the football but the big thing is
he needs to be able to take hits and do
that and yeah you know here's the other
interesting aspect of this mic too like
just i want to hear your take you know
if you're the if you're the saints
you know you don't really want to throw
a 90 or 85 percent drew brees out there
in this game and then what okay maybe he
doesn't play as well maybe you lose by
20 points to the chiefs and patrick
mahomes you know if that happened to
where you have to play in the super bowl
again i think that has a psychological
effect on your football team a little
bit to where i don't know if i'd want
the chiefs to have that you know
advantage on me or my team to think that
way to where i would be reluctant as
long as that's as far as that's
concerned too
you have a little max headroom action
there with your i saw that camera hook
up yeah that was good that was good it
actually had the max headroom sound
effect there for a second but you heard
me right you can still hear me so i
heard everything you said i heard
everything you said and everything you
said for a change made sense the idea of
it that you don't want to put brees out
there if he's diminished when we had
sean payton on the pft pm show last week
he he said look you've got all that
torquing all those muscles in the rib
cage when you try to turn to throw a
football there's going to be pain
there's going to be discomfort and you
know whether or not they have a
an appointment between drew brees and dr
needle there are potential complications
from that as well so
yeah you go with the guy who's healthy
if he's playing well enough and and
don't listen to this nonsense just
because he had one bad game taysom hill
doesn't have it what quarterback is
great every single week who's great
every single week and it wasn't hill it
was the defense on sunday that betrayed
the saints you give up 250 rushing yards
doesn't matter who's playing quarterback
you have 250 rushing yards you're gonna
have a hard time winning the football
game chris
yeah that's exactly right and the saints
went into the game i think with a little
bit of arrogance i think they just
thought hey we're we're on fire we're
the saints and we're just gonna beat you
we're not gonna change up a whole lot of
what we do
and it's just you might know what we're
gonna do and so what and they they you
know hit a team that no could physically
match them that way and hey yeah we
talked about a lot the fact that there
was no jalen hurts game plan i i still
don't understand that
definitely not
and
you know you're totally right about the
taysom hill thing too in the first half
of that football game listen it wasn't
taysom hill that was the issue or
anything like that you know the big
issue was i would say is sean payton he
just they were a little too run centric
and then of course they missed a field
goal then made some mistakes there too
that hurt their football team but when
they came out in the second half and
they kind of played pass first and
played through the pass game taysom hill
played really well you can't you know
the fourth and one fumble okay yeah he
made a mistake he you know there's
people open he should have hit michael
thomas at the very least it's not a
perfect game you're going to make
mistakes but i mean i think to your
point is what i'm saying is it's not
time to panic or go oh we got to get
drew in there because tasem looks so bad
we have no chance no that's not the case
at all
and the question that i have when drew
is able to come back how different will
that offense look in comparison to what
it was pre-injury will we see more
taysom hill we spent a large chunk of
the early part of the season saying
why aren't they using this guy more he
was great in the playoff loss to the
vikings and it just felt like they were
using him sparingly maybe they won't
with the season
on the line as they get closer and
closer to the playoffs when they get
into january i think we'll see more of
him
regardless of what drew brees situation
is i just think it's smart to use your
best players and hill is clearly one of
their best players right now other
quarterback news let's swing up to new
york where the giants will be playing
the browns on sunday night football
here's daniel jones the starting
quarterback who has hamstring problem
ankle injury he was asked yesterday if
he's hurting the team by trying to play
while he's injured
would it ever enter your mind that with
a sore hamstring with a sore ankle that
going out there would hurt the team and
is that something you would consider
uh that's you know not a decision that
that's uh up to me i don't i don't make
those decisions my job is to prepare to
play and you know do everything i can to
to be prepared
yeah look i mean
it really isn't up to him the coach says
you're going to play you're going to
play it's up to the coaching staff to
decide whether or not it's hurting the
team to have a guy out there who isn't
100 and whether or not it's hurting the
guy to be out there if he's not 100
percent i i don't think right he was 100
by any stretch on sunday against the
cardinals and he emerges from the game
with an ankle injury possibly
a product of playing when he had a bad
hamstring
definitely i mean you know you he's
being careful he certainly wasn't
running like we you know usually see him
run with the football last week i think
there was definitely a
a conscious effort to not move him in
the pocket and also for the quick
passing game last week because i think
they didn't want him to you know hold
the ball too long and then have to run
and move the pocket and do those type of
things as well
some point in the game he obviously
aggravated it too so it's the hamstring
that and and listen the coach makes a
decision
but it is on the player to a degree to
let him know like
where you're at realistically you know
you don't want to go into the game and
just play
and okay i want to play for my own
personal
i want to play because i don't want the
backup to get in the football game and
have him have success and maybe they win
without me and do all that okay i know
that's tough as a starting quarterback
but you also don't want to go in the
game
where okay i can't function and i'm
hurting the football team you know when
it gets to that point you do have to be
realistic with the coach and have a
man's to man conversation there just to
let him know i think that's very real
all right so uh i do think it's on him a
little more than he's trying to let on
too and and one last thing mike
man his running is such a big part of
this offense
they need him i mean especially against
cleveland we saw their run defense is
not good and daniel jones is second on
the giants and rushing behind wayne
gallman he's a bit that's a big part of
what they do to help their offense out
they're not that explosive so to not
have that really hinders their chance to
pull off an upset or beat the cleveland
browns
colt mccoy didn't have a huge game
statistically when the giants went to
seattle and beat the seahawks and this
is the same analysis we talked about
earlier do you take daniel jones at less
than 100 percent or colt mccoy at 100
percent the giants clearly made the
strategic decision against the cardinals
to go with a diminished jones over a
healthy mccoy and we'll see if they make
that decision on sunday night when the
giants host the browns a huge game for
the giants they now have to make up a
game against washington down the stretch
or they will not make it to the playoffs
and for a while it was just starting to
feel like it was destined that joe judge
would take the giants to the playoffs in
his first season with the team a couple
of other quarterback issues let's stay
in the nfc east alex smith the
washington football team quarterback
calf injury he says he feels all right
but he's uncertain if he can play on
sunday against the seahawks that would
put
the guy who had become persona non grata
dwayne haskins back on the field i mean
he didn't blow it on sunday i mean when
you have a great defense just you know
you don't need the offense to do much
but but it's one thing to have dwayne
haskins thrust into the game it's
another thing to give the seahawks a
chance to game plan for him if he's
going to be the guy obviously chris
washington has a much better chance of
winning if alex smith is playing
quarterback
yeah definitely but i i don't think it's
crazy to think that they could somehow
pull off a win with dwayne haskins now
dwayne haskins yeah he's not going to be
able to manage the football game he's
going to have to really play a
conservative type of football and not be
you know
a young stud and try to show everybody
he's got a big right arm and he can fit
in a ball in between you know jamal
adams and bobby wagner down the middle
you got to realize what your team is he
did look comfortable last week i'll give
him that you know guys on the team
seemed to be happy for him that he was
playing in the game
and you know he seemed like he knew
where he wanted to go with the ball
they're gonna have to manage him a
little bit certainly but uh yeah it
lessens their chances of me thinking
washington can pull off a win there if
alex smith is not in the in the football
game
lions quarterback matthew stafford on
the injury report with a
rib which i guess means only one because
with brees it was ribs and we eventually
found out reportedly it's 11. still that
one is enough to keep matthew stafford
out of practice he's got a lingering
right thumb problem he's not ruling
himself out for sunday at tennessee the
lions playing out the string here but
stafford
trying to put some film together that
may get someone else interested
potentially if it's not in the cards for
him to stay in detroit that's just one
of the many questions that needs to be
resolved but you know you want to finish
strong whether to impress the new
coaching staff if you do want to stay or
to get yourself higher on the list of
quarterbacks that another team may be
thinking about bringing in he could be
an equivalent to a philip rivers a tom
brady a guy who leaves the place he's
been for a long time and it's been a
very long time in detroit and go
somewhere else next year
yeah except you know he's closer to his
prime of his career than those guys are
at least you know that's that's where it
could be interesting and i think there's
a number of teams that
kind of quietly have matthew stafford on
their radar for for you know the chances
or the circumstances that you mentioned
that he's not there with the lions and i
think there's a very real possibility
that that marriage ends certainly
matthew stafford
if he can play in this football game you
know this titan's past defense we know
it's crappy so
he can make things interesting i really
do think so with with their offense and
the kind of the balance they have a
little bit
that's a big game changer there you know
the titans are going to move the ball at
will on the lions that is for sure i
mean derek henry could have 200 yards
rushing again this week it's a very real
possibility but you know yeah if it
wants to be a competitive game they need
stafford out there to make some of those
big throws that he usually makes
i just don't think stafford's ever
gotten the highest level of coaching
that he needs to get the most out of him
given his unique degrees he's he's not
the the the prototypical sheriff
he's not the natural-born leader he's
almost more of an eli manning than a
peyton manning and and and i think what
you need is a locker room and an
organization where the leadership comes
from other places
and he's just asked to go out and throw
the football i think that's all he wants
to do and that's fine it's it i've
always sensed that about matthew
stafford and i've always sensed he
hasn't gotten that right button pressing
the right motivation the right coaching
the right guidance to be the absolute
best he can be he's still been pretty
damn good but i'm talking about winning
i just feel like it hasn't fallen
together for him and there's got to be a
coach out there thinking if i get him in
here in my organization with my locker
room with my coaching staff with my
players he's going to be uh he's going
to be even better
oh yeah i i chris i know now he's back
i'm back you hear me now yep i know i
got
you cut out on me just a little bit but
i i heard most of that
and i mean mike you're spot on i only
heard what you said in the beginning and
the end but either way i think you're
spot on there you know again it's not
always
we put quarterbacks on a pedestal where
we expect them
to
be the culture of the football team
sometimes and that's very rare that that
really happens it's very rare and in
fact i would say with most of the great
quarterbacks of all time the ones we
really hold in the pantheon the super
bowl quarterbacks that was never
expected of them you know terry bradshaw
was about the defense and chuck knoll i
mean the 49ers it was it was bill walsh
said the the the culture there you know
we know that you know certainly and of
course with tom brady and the patriots
is the same way too
but at times i feel like we give those
guys credit for all that and i want to
go no if you put matthew stafford in
some of those situations
his career would look a whole lot
different he hasn't had crap ola around
him his whole career i mean the
100-yard rushers didn't happen the first
nine years of his career you know
defense stink yeah okay he had calvin
johnson what would he do for uh for the
first four or five years that's all he
had though i mean it was nothing else
crappy o-line no run game no defense
matt stafford keep them close you know
win some games with magic
uh they should really be three and 13
but now they're 7-9 and miss the
playoffs and everybody blames matt
stafford when it's really like no the
only reason they were competitive was
because of matt stafford and calvin
johnson and that's where i think the
conversation goes wrong at least in my
eyes
we've never seen a situation like this
where a quarterback stayed for so long
with one team without achieving a truly
high degree of success he has a 5 000
yard season or two
but or close to a second one i think but
but not the postseason success the idea
that he could pivot to another team and
find that success elsewhere fascinating
possibility and there will be a coach
out there secretly plotting for a bright
future with matthew stafford
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports